depuis quelques mois hamada traoré
collectionne les amendes pour
stationnement gênant
et pour cause avec une douzaine de
places pour la maison de quartier
mendès-france les écoles fromont et
carpentier et la salle de prière de
l'association des musulmans se garer rue
guy barillot à guyancourt relève du défi
au moment des prières c'est à chaque
fois le même scénario les voitures sans
fil sur ou à côté du trottoir
la justice se transforme à moi j'aurais
bien voulu quand même que qu'on me dise
on lui dit s'est pas matérialisée je
suis entièrement d'accord avec eux mais
au moins faire comprendre aux gens par
quelque chose par ainsi qu'on ne peut
pas se garer la wii soit une
interdiction soit une interdiction fin
février à mada traoré a alors demandé à
la mairie de créer plus de places lors
d'un entretien avec le responsable des
associations
de son côté la ville de guyancourt
refuse d'ajouter des emplacements car un
parking est ouvert à 200 mètres de la
rue et la voie étant étroite cela
poserait des problèmes de sécurité pour
les enfants
la situation est en tout cas loin d'être
réglée puisque dans quelques semaines le
local associatif va s'agrandir